yeah thing do I need anything I need a
few bullets to the face
shoot me really hard lovely how hard
they shoot you is gonna affect any his
name is trigger-happy leet he's gonna
shoot me show me no man
shoot me never shoot kill me in my face
God that sounds horrifying he did it oh
good job that's good that's [ __ ] funny
wait what if that's a thing what if I
just start yelling and then do the thing
and this was like can you find me
hello anything no I see someone running
up a hill up a road is that you might be
me I just ran into a wolf
where are you did you just turn around
yeah I did I see you Clark I'm coming
you're right you're right am i right we
got more honorable you guys did we might
want to run away
up and out ah help me hey kill him kill
him stop sprinting
I can't sprint and hit him well how am I
supposed to run away he's gonna bite me
wampum wampum good way be pumping harder
than that we've got we've got medkits
hahaha
we want them good good job Bob now many
people on this service so hopefully whoa
oh oh that was you I was like who's
there I'm gonna murder you
no no Boone hey hey look at that if you
hold ye on a fire hung it works no
that's impossible
yes sir no way chickens hello
am i there may or may be about to have
to kill a wall there may or may not be a
wolf away oh there he is there is he's
coming he's coming oh god he's out help
huh which ones yeah
are you he's following you can't lead
him away from the lighter I can't see
him
[ __ ] you have I got ten cloth from him I
have ten right now fifteen I can make
one alright do it I'm doing it and then
we get murdered
OOP oh that's adorable you okay are fed
or is this our camp is it did we
officially make this our camp is that
how this magic worries gonna start it's
a set yeah this is our camp now oh yeah
hey finally so I put down a foundation
right yeah
oh you can't even say no no I put it
down but it's so dark you can't see it I
am currently out of torches then I put a
pillow right oh can I put my my wood
doorway onto this hang on I got to put
the pillars down I put the pillars on
the four corners of it right yeah you
cannot see this but it is there oh my
gosh I can actually put my doorway on
this yeah we'll just stand here uh-huh
do you want to sing a song oh yeah the
greatest stupid game where we can't find
our friends how about that that was
technically a song yeah yeah I found
another wolf can they bring it back oh
god yeah okay I'll meet you back at camp
kill it i crap another wolf what the
hell
you gotta be kidding me I found some
anti-radiation post on hospital Oh crowd
I'm dying
do you have any stones or anything no
but I just found a rock yeah oh I've
never been so happy to find a rock up a
big one atop bigan not your breath you
think you go out here huh guy guy shot
me in the face please
you were screaming at him to you in the
lake if you were tall if you think back
if you're really really way you really
think about it dad back please tell me
that's you the footsteps are here okay
that's me oh yeah yeah
of us and get into at the same time ah
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to rust you know with
Bob that's me yeah I wish I had a
graphic for that yeah that's me
that's that's Bob like a Looney Tunes
thing with the shiny I'll try to I'll do
something but it'll probably really low
budget and crappy but I'll do my best
Barry give me a graphic Barry come on do
we say that sure we can Barry it's not
gonna happen but Barry come on come on
Barry okay sandy we got something in
there Barry yeah whatever Oh Harry oh I
don't know who is Barry I don't know do
you actually not know who Barry is like
comment subscribe if you know who yeah
if you know who Barry is please rate
comment and subscribe for the game
grumps cuz that's where he is over there
but anyway I tossed chicken breasts on
the ground there Bob it's cooked I'm
gonna make a inside campfire in here
yeah you know what else we can do we can
make steers in this thing
what well where wood stairs
okay don't I don't know also we didn't
really think about expanding this
particular one so well all you need is
like another foundation then right yeah
I guess it's simple yes yeah but the
wood walls that we can't seem to remove
or I don't know how to do that well you
just use the doors it'll be it'll be
compartmentalize oh but then I won't be
able to get into my eye
well we just make sure that we keep two
exterior doors that we can better
appropriate oh there's so much work I
don't wanna do that but you just okay
fine whatever you dickbag I don't call
me a dick bag alright so do you have any
stones I have four what do you need you
need a hatchet I what I would live a
hatchet you have any stone at all you
have any stone no damn Bible we need one
more stone you dick how long okay I'm
sorry I'm just lashing out it's been
very hard to get this set up guys once
again Russ takes some prep work
apparently
you don't just one does not simply play
Russ yeah those good I like that that
was good yeah it's good reference even
from 12 years ago yeah
irrelevant still relevant hey I just
recently bought the blu-ray edition of
the extended Lord of the Rings the
ultimate final ultimate director's
extended yeah yeah I'm Terra Cotta mama
no I'm gonna make a whole day of it I'm
gonna watch I see a rock oh my gosh I
see a rock over there big with no water
fire what which way down the hill you go
up the hill all go down the hill
oh but okay don't just up there up the
hill sucks
shut up no it doesn't does it I don't
know probably I put all my stuff in
storage in case I run into someone again
and get murdered I don't know if I close
that door to the special storage area
you know the secondary storage that I
made specifically to house our most
valuable of material uh dad I'm a
therapist yeah oh hold out on me bro no
no what no no way people not on me yes I
am very much so but that doesn't matter
because I'm learning together and we're
happy family right balls oh so I have a
question that I know you don't know the
answer to okay
there are pickaxes in this game
apparently what's the point of that can
you actually like dig into the earth do
not think so that would be very weird if
you could god is that a bear or a boar
oh it's a bear oh no did you attract its
attention to tie up what the hell did
you get it I saw this I found a
structure surrounded by bears
hahaha I don't know if this is worth it
where's retracted by the administration
hey that's for me old one yeah that is
Robert the new I'm killing this Boris
I'm lumping it good
well I just found a rock but all it gave
me is like 9000 or god dammit well when
we finally got a cup when we finally get
the furnace we're gonna have plenty of
metal so the question of the day is Oh
prick never mind what you do huh
attracted to bears same time I'm not
gonna help you kill those actually not
trying kill bears are slower than wolves
I think so you can get away from those
or should be able I I'm also on the roof
of this house where I was earlier and
I'm gonna see if this dude's home and
try and loot his stuff again is that the
guy that killed you earlier yeah uh
pretty much only because he killed me am
i coming back to do this well are you
going to be able to kill him cuz I don't
wash it's empty anyway oh okay you know
there's crap it's a trap it probably is
a trap isn't it maybe uh I think I see
another Rock I thought I saw another
Rock everything kind of also they spit
they're really pissed that I'm here yeah
[Music]
something like that
I'm I'm out of here I got another Rock
oh my gosh that was the wrong way to run
okay I've got 12 stone now yeah man I
need more stone you can you're good with
the hand Rock for a bit if we can make a
furnace right yeah yeah cuz we can make
we only need 15 ml furnace the [ __ ]
mayor won't leave me alone I've got four
stones right now uh assuming I make it
back alive yeah assuming that Eddy if I
hide behind this rock the bear will
forget I exist there's a I found a place
with like a furnace there's are really
freaking slow-cooked ice with a furnace
like up oh my god I think I found
someone else's sheltering oh my god I
got it don't get killed I'm coming back
what is it the Bears yes don't get
killed by the Bears there are three of
them now and I found like a field full
wonder and awesomeness yeah and I'm
being chased through it by a goddamn
thing
why are you constantly attracting
attention on the boar
bears oh my god I can literally see five
or six stacks of wood and five rocks oh
no don't do it the bear left the pair
left I'm gonna be quiet you said there
were three bears they're gone you should
hold out half you should hold down your
mic button and just yell at the Bears
hey bears hey bears hey I don't think
they heard no okay what if that did what
if they your voice you're really awesome
if all the Bears were just like oh right
kill that guy
maybe if you just growl low to him
they'll come running oh that's uh I hope
someone's standing right behind me let's
go to the entire company I am as crazy
as you think I wonder if the louder you
yell into the microphone the farther it
carries huh I kind of got that
impression when you were screaming at me
earlier really I was like echoing
through the hill oh that's so cool she
just play with that for a while I'm
gonna stay out of not build stuff just
experiment with the echo again can you
hear me from this ah no oh boy damn it
help some other people cuz I like
standing on top and point to myself down
at a valley reading from the top of the
night hahahahaha I really hope that
worked and then again I really hope it
doesn't because people might come
a-runnin that one fan of mine is give me
more glare oh don't worry ogre gave you
with bullets to the face good dang it
okay uh I haven't found any more rocks
did you get any more rocks uh I
currently have seven still of sulfur 10
stones 23 metal ores yay I actually
found like a place July come back what
what a pound stone a stone oh I found a
rock is what I meant to say it's that's
that's good thank you thank you very
much I'm happy you're happy for me here
I'm happy you're happy
happy birthday I'm happy that I'm oh my
god don't die a person is being chased
by a bear when I think he's gonna try
and kill me while he's being chased by a
bear away from him is that strudel
humper [ __ ] no I think it's the guy
whose house I broke into twice now oh
okay you want some assistance what do
you want strudel don't kill me I don't
think that's strudel is that strudel oh
god it's so good murdering oh god oh god
there's someone with a gun looking at
our camp Oh God
oh my god are you kidding me but oh god
oh god
Oh what do I do Oh what do I do I'm
hiding behind a rock yeah let's just
hide well I'm gonna let him go away
Oh God do I hear I hear stealthy well
I'm coming up the hill a little just be
careful look you let me go thank you Oh
oh good forgot I hear him oh no did he
see you what I hear him oh you went away
oh you run away keep going keep going
I think you ma'am here heard me Tarzan
ting wait oh you went by again oh man I
wish I had a sniper rifle I'm watching a
guy who's like 500 yards away totally
just like run around in the open like a
[ __ ] hmm oh no no no no no gonna kill
me giggling Bobby's gonna kill me can
you get inside our know I'm trapped
under a rock he's pacing around to be
right now I can hear him
Bob help me Bob please up I got nothing
dude Bob LV please why don't we have
guns yet oh okay he's running don't turn
around
oh oh where's he going
don't let him hear you cry like a little
baby
it said oh my god
what I happened upon a house and there
was a dude god how are you sir Oh sugar
happy
yeah it's you oh god I thought you were
you oh it's it's true Bob it's trigger
happy yeah yeah oh yeah you're the best
Bobby gave me a hunting bow wow really I
was scared for my life and you came and
saved me you heard me before but I asked
for that Bob it's okay he's come to join
us football it's come to drink I'll be
recording this the whole world is gonna
see you're Murphy ha ha Bob Cabana
highball I don't know where I am
bottom back to callused mark applause
it's ok it's ok
we're gonna be ok I've got food and a
gun rock and a bunch of stuff well I'm
lost you don't know how scared I was
when I saw you
oh sorry forever trigger is he talking
to you can you hear him I can hear I
wish I could hear don't yell hey rigger
yo for Bob we're gonna try to get Bob
here oh my god that does get louder when
he gets louder it's still weird
oh wait bother you Bob Lee Bob come back
it's us it's us
it's me Tom Bob Becker wait oh hey hey
hey
no he's cool he's cool oh cool he's cool
he's our new friend
I like how you wearing a burglars outfit
Hey look shotgun shells I guess mine
mine but I don't have a shotgun now
that's not as useful as I thought it
would be yeah
oh god this is so weird ok alright
oh look you got a shotgun oh I have a
shotgun now
oh why are you being so nice everyone
always just kills us in this game did I
know who you are that's why yeah cuz he
knows Marga Barbet think oh my god why
is sight even look at that yeah yeah oh
you're more stuff of my dad wanted oh no
we're gonna survive on our own but we
truly appreciate this everyone in the
comments below say how awesome
trigger-happy Lee trigger-happy is the
savior of markiplier she's fine but he
saved markiplier yeah can I give a
shout-out to myself just fine whatever
you earned it yeah I have a youtube
channel it's what you cut out to cut out
dude okay the random gamer a random
gamer comment on this video you comment
on this video because you're awesome
yeah now the only thing we ask in return
is let us survive on our own and that'll
be it yeah yes ma'am yes okay also less
lady yes don't kill us later that's
really funny unless it's funny don't
kill us I'm not I'm not I'm not okay
with the funny killing okay either way
but thank you again just oh yes thank
you yeah I guess don't kill us
Bob doesn't want to die okay thank you
still here oh yeah oh my god turned out
better I was so scared shotgun with a
laser sight in like 30 some chills is
bad I'm gonna OH
gonna go kill that dude who didn't kill
me earlier booth applause yeah Oh in our
beds and put them into the well I'm
gonna take my I'm gonna leave them in
here is just this is like the secret
base
oh no wait you're right the bed the bed
should be in there because we both need
to be able to open those
all right I'm coming in my door aren't
so awesome
it's so cool I'm gonna sleep right next
to the fire here this is my thought the
only good experience from Rossi although
that other guy that I ran into strudel
was his face he was cool he did he saw
me in his house and he was all hey what
you doing this is my house why are you
ha ha
I can just leave lol ha ha yeah he does
hunting bows and shotguns ya know that's
the oh man I've rationed kits big and
small med kits in here of Valor just
kids what the heck oh gosh in kits gives
750 calories 6 liters of water I don't
even know what that means but it also
reduces your rads by 300 and gives you
35 health it's the bomb dude that guy
was awesome
hey I actually finally I have a shotgun
with a laser sight yeah and I'm about to
get a hatchet yeah and we're all son of
a oh dang it no I'm not about that what
what are you about to make a furnace ok
why have you had a low-grade fuel for a
furnace I do I actually have everything
I need for a furnace oh can you make
that and set it up in here and I'll
start you Stang on I got to get the
low-grade fuel out of my secret stash of
Wonders super secret hiding spot yeah
what was that you hopping around hey get
out my super stache tonight but good I'm
putting my stuff in I'm gonna take the
metal ore out and make metal fragments
with it John putting do you need more
stone no I got just enough stone just
let me have the fuel I need that to make
the furnace ok uh yeah go nuts thank you
for getting out of my thing oh it's it's
our stuff I helped
whatever-whatever I was there know what
what I'm locked in hey I'm locked in I
know Hey ok mark yeah yeah mark time ok
ok ah this is awesome
anyway this is all the time we have for
this part in this one so thank you all
so much for watching we got so much cool
stuff now thank you trigger-happy for
being an awesome person and not a total
dick monkey yeah and if he comes out of
that corner is where I'm gonna put the
print
why are these rocks pulsing they're just
rocks rocks rocks rocks rust from Rob's
rubber Preston
that's how rocks are exactly not fair
that's not fair that was not fair what
can i push this
alright that was awesome oh it was so
cool
I can't believe I have a shotgun yeah
you're like naturally Murray looking
Naked bum with a shotgun you're the
epitome of very dangerous person oh this
is what Detroit is exactly just earth
yeah actually that shotgun looks like a
machine gun with noclip in it for some
reason I don't know why I guess they
just died out loud texture I don't like
can you third person in this I don't
maybe have five now you can't we tried
that before we couldn't have a third
person for some reason yeah all right
don't you erase all I'm gonna use the
furnace okay you do that
um oh and it's so cool yeah I'm a [ __ ]
- almost bum with a helmet on yeah Oh
like all this guy with the big help no
it's good yeah oh and a hunting bow that
looks like it's made out of finding
thank you Oh what else could we make oh
my gosh well there's a bunch of animal
fat oh gosh blood okay we got about a
few hours left until night or not hours
but you know he knows some amount of
time yeah so can I make a stone hatchet
is that a thing oh I can't make it stop
maybe do you want to cook the sulfur -
or just focus on the middle first I want
to get the metal uh taken care of first
okay how much we need for need eight
some more stones for a workbench do you
have eight stones uh I believe I'd stuck
five 10 stones yeah I'll wait workbench
and we can get that well actually I
might have everything I need to craft a
workbench myself yeah I'm gonna put my
sleeping bag right next year so we have
it yeah corner I'm gonna craft a
workbench and put it in here there we go
now you send cozy I'll put it right next
to the furnace here yeah yeah yeah are
you gonna put it down or what oh there
we go
oh it's so cool so cozy maybe a Skyrim
for selection does it work
oh okay - it opens next one